Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Il cortisolo, e l'adrenalina,
che servono per, come dire,
avere la vostra attenzione.
Cortisolo e adrenalina
sono gli ingredienti necessari
per fare in modo che tutto quello
che poi vi spiegherò, tra pochissimo,
venga tenuto dal vostro cervello,
e conservato per essere poi divulgato.
Il problema del cortisolo,
uno dei problemi del cortisolo,
è che poi crea un po' di stress.
Come si compensa il cortisolo?
Molto facilmente con, per esempio,
endorfine e serotonina.
Tra le cose che potete fare,
per produrre endorfine e serotonina,
ci sono parole di conforto,
oppure applausi -
(Applausi)
Bene, bene, bene.
E adesso che siamo di buon umore,
vi parlo di odore di ascella.
(Risate)
Che uno dice: non è proprio tra gli inizi
più straordinari di questo mondo.
E invece no: odore di ascelle.
Immaginatevi: puzza di ascella.
Voglio insistere con le parole,
per farvi sperimentare
quello che le parole
possono fare nel vostro cervello
senza che voi, ahimè, spesso lo sappiate.
Ce l'avete in mente
l'odore di ascella, sì o no?
Pubblico: Sì.
PB: Ok. Ce l'ho anch'io qua, tra l'altro.
C'è questa ricerca del 2005
in cui a un gruppo di persone
viene fatta annusare una sostanza,
tipo questa, contenuta
in un'ampolla di vetro trasparente -
sostanza trasparente, senza etichette -
senza dire nulla, tranne una cosa:
"Stai per annusare odore di ascelle".
E le persone che devono sniffare
questa sostanza così odorosa,
così simpaticamente odorosa,
hanno delle reazioni che sono
assolutamente prevedibili,
fanno una faccia
che è assolutamente prevedibile.
Che ora io vi simulo:
ma che vi chiederei di interpretare
per sentire come funziona questa cosa.
Fanno una faccia più o meno che è così.
Fatela anche voi, almeno siamo allineati
e mi sento un po' meno solo.
Così.
(Smorfia di disgusto)
Che è la tipica espressione
facciale del disgusto.
Perché?
Perché il nostro sistema
biologico, per proteggerci,
ci fa provare ribrezzo per alcune cose,
tra cui gli odori del nostro corpo,
per evitare ad alcune persone
che altrimenti berrebbero,
mangerebbero cose
che, insomma, non si devono
né bere né mangiare.
Questo è il sistema biologico.
Il sistema nervoso di queste persone
ha delle reazioni che sono prevedibili:
si agitano, la pupilla
si restringe - si chiama miosi.
Addirittura si accende,
nel cervello di queste persone,
la "Pain Area":
"Pain" vuol dire dolore.
L'area del dolore.
Che è quella che vi si accende in testa
quando, per esempio, pagate in contanti
invece che con la carta di credito.
Avete presente quella sensazione?
(Risate)
"Pain Area": adesso avete
un nome scientifico
per chiamare questa cosa.
E ci sta: è prevedibile, insomma.
Quando ho iniziato con "odore di ascella",
avete avuto una reazione prevedibile.
La cosa molto interessante,
di questa ricerca,
è che ad altre persone
viene fatta annusare
la stessa sostanza trasparente,
proveniente dalla stessa ampolla,
con una differenza importante:
a queste persone si dice
che stanno per annusare
un particolare profumo
di un particolare formaggio francese,
invecchiato tantissimi anni,
quindi una cosa molto preziosa,
che costa milioni di euro al chilo.
E poi si dice loro: "Annusa".
Queste persone hanno una reazione,
anche in questo caso, prevedibile;
ma molto, molto diversa.
La pupilla non si restringe: si dilata!
La pupilla si dilata
quando noi ci aspettiamo
una ricompensa molto forte,
un piacere molto intenso.
Si chiama "attivazione
del circuito dopaminergico".
Quando ci aspettiamo
qualcosa di molto bello,
quando per esempio vogliamo
comprare un bene di lusso,
o vediamo un piatto
che ci affascina moltissimo,
si accende una parte del cervello
diversa da quella di prima.
Si chiama "nucleus accumbens",
che è una parte del cervello
che per l'appunto ci fa pregustare
piaceri incredibili,
e ci fa spendere un sacco di soldi.
Quando comprate cose
che sapete, col cervello inconscio,
che non dovreste comprare,
la colpa è sua.
Quindi, la prossima volta
che tornate a casa,
e vi sgridano perché avete comprato
una cosa che non vi serve,
voi alzate le mani e dite:
"È il nucleus accumbens, io non c'ero!".
Che non è così distante dalla verità.
Io mi occupo da 15, quasi venti adesso -
non mi piace ammetterlo,
ma quasi vent'anni -
di intelligenza linguistica,
cioè dell'effetto che le parole
hanno sul nostro cervello.
A livello fisico, a livello fisiologico.
Cosa fanno le parole della nostra realtà?
Come ci fanno stare?
E tra tutte le ricerche
con cui sono entrato in contatto,
questa sicuramente è una di quelle
che più mi ha scaldato,
che più mi ha affascinato -
e più mi ha inquietato.
E dovrebbe inquietare un po' anche voi.
Perché?
Perché quella fiala siete voi.
Quella fiala siete voi,
ogni giorno della vostra vita.
Quando vi presentate agli altri,
senza saperlo voi fate o l'effetto -
quello lì, ok? quello dell'ascella -
Oppure l'altro effetto.
La cosa interessante di quell'esperimento
è che la stessa cosa, con parole diverse,
da un lato sconvolge delle persone,
e fa provare loro sensazioni spiacevoli;
dall'altro lato, le eccita.
La stessa sostanza!
Diverse le parole, diverse le reazioni;
e quella fiala siete voi, siamo noi,
tutti i giorni della nostra vita.
Quando chiamate qualcuno e dite:
"Scusami, ti disturbo? ",
voi fate l'effetto dell'odore di ascella
Ma è così, perché "disturbo",
per esempio, magari voi non lo sapete,
ma è un frame, attiva un'idea,
una serie di immagini
che hanno a che fare, guarda caso,
con una delle paure più inconsce,
tipiche e ataviche dell'essere umano:
la paura dei rumori forti.
Come esseri umani, per sopravvivere,
noi siamo progettati per temere
i disturbi e i rumori forti.
E la cosa migliore che riusciamo a fare
è chiedere a qualcuno
se possiamo disturbarlo, "scusandoci".
Che è una parola che a livello
di pura semantica, in italiano, significa:
"So che sto per farti male,
mi ci sento in colpa,
e lo faccio lo stesso".
(Risate)
È affascinante: voi ridete,
ma è un po' drammatica, la faccenda.
Perché facciamo questo?
Perché vogliamo essere gentili.
È solo che essere gentili,
e poi apparire come ascella pezzata,
non è tra le cose
che reputo più interessanti.
Potremmo fare in maniera diversa:
potremmo eccitarle, le persone.
Potremmo chiamare qualcuno
e dire "Ciao, sei libero?"
Perché la parola "libertà" -
pensateci, mentre lo dico -
la parola libertà evoca in sequenza:
la spiaggia -
Lo so cosa pensate!
Montagne; colline;
cieli azzurri; uccellini che volano.
Persone che fanno così, giusto?
Quella roba lì, che voi pensate,
diventa endorfine.
E fa quell'altro effetto: sempre gentili,
ma con un effetto completamente diverso.
Quando fate un regalo a qualcuno
e dite, tremando: "Guarda,
ho un pensierino per te.
Ma è proprio una
sciocchezza, una stupidata!
Guarda, niente di che: la prima cosa
che mi è capitata sottomano.
Se non ti piace, lo puoi cambiare".
(Risate)
Ridete, poi tornate a casa e dite:
"E però non mi danno valore,
però non - riciclano i miei regali!"
E per forza!
Puoi dire - vi svelo
un mistero straordinario.
Potreste dire: "Ho un regalo per te!".
Segnatevelo, perché -
(Applausi)
Scrivete, scrivete perché poi dite:
"Mi dimentico". Eh no, scrivete!
Avete il blocco per gli appunti
ecologico, scrivete.
E la prossima volta -
io, a volte, mi intristisco
perché vedo tanta gente
che ha le buone intenzioni,
e poi magari non ce la fa.
La prossima volta che cucinate per 24 ore,
per fare la cena
ai vostri parenti e amici,
quando vi diranno "Che buona la cena",
invece di cominciare con:
"Si, però il branzino era insipido -
(Risate)
La pasta era un po scotta,
e i cavoli non erano buoni -"
Li guardate negli occhi,
e dite: "Ah, sì? Vero buongustaio"
Almeno daranno valore a quello che dite.
(Applausi)
Quella fiala siete voi,
ma quella fiala sono io.
Sono io: qui mi vedete alla guida
della mia prima e unica Lamborghini;
e lì mi vedete su un palco.
Qual è la differenza? Sono sempre io.
Prima balbettavo, ero timido, introverso,
mi presentavo male e nessuno mi ascoltava.
Io ho balbettato fino a vent'anni:
curioso essere a fare
questa cosa bellissima.
Adesso, quando mi dicono:
"Ci sono 700 persone sedute",
con un certo snobismo dico:
"Ah, ok. Speravo mille!"
(Risate)
E sono sempre lo stesso:
ho cambiato la narrazione
della mia storia,
ho scoperto che esiste una cosa
che si chiama "Abracadabra".
Dall'Aramaico, "Avrà ka davrà"
che significa: "Io creo cose come parlo".
La parola diventa realtà.
È mito?
È magia?
È scienza?
È scienza: Abracadabra è scienza!
Quello che succede è quello
che vi ho descritto prima,
in pochi secondi.
Ogni parola che voi pensate,
concepite, immaginate,
produce l'accensione nel cervello,
sentite?
L'ho voluto ripetere
due volte per ricordarmi,
perché un conto è dire che balbetti,
un conto è dire: ripeto i concetti,
così almeno la gente capisce.
È una storia diversa.
Accende diverse aree del cervello,
che a loro volta producono
delle reazioni chimiche ormonali
come quelle che avete sentito prima
quando ho detto "odore di ascella".
L'avete sentito! Era fisico! Erano ormoni!
E quegli ormoni lì
diventano la vostra realtà.
La realtà che voi vivete ogni giorno,
e questa è scienza,
è il risultato delle parole
che usate per raccontarla.
E la cosa bellissima è che,
se non vi piace la realtà,
potete cambiare le parole.
È un po' come sulle montagne russe.
Faccio sempre questo esempio,
perché secondo me è molto significativo.
Pensateci mentre lo faccio,
perché alcuni di voi, sicuramente,
saranno iperappassionati di montagne russe
e altri meno.
Io, di sicuro, sono di quelli
che le montagne russe,
se può evitarle, le evita.
Se le conosci le eviti: io le evito.
Alcune persone le amano molto, invece;
altre ne sono terrorizzate.
Ora, immaginate di prendere due persone -
una innamorata persa delle montagne russe,
una invece che non le sopporta proprio -
e di metterle sulla prima carrozza
che va giù - ce l'avete presente? -
e di far fare loro un paio di capovolte,
cosa che non riesco neanche a concepire.
Poi immaginate di prendere queste persone,
alla fine del loro giro della morte -
che solo a dirlo, comunque,
l'amigdala si accende e dice: "Cosa fai? "
Non ci devi andare,
nel giro della morte!" -
Abbiamo l'amigdala,
che ci protegge da questa cosa.
Insomma, le prendete e chiedete loro
che cosa hanno voglia di fare,
dopo il giro della morte.
Loro ti diranno, tutte e due,
che hanno voglia impellente
di andare in bagno.
Perché il nostro sistema biologico
è progettato, di fronte
a un pericolo reale, imminente,
per farci vuotare le viscere,
fare pipì o altro.
Lo sapete: quando avete paura, voi dite
"Me la sono fatta sotto dalla paura".
Perché lo dite?
Perché il corpo parla, il corpo sa.
Quindi, entrambe
dovranno andare a fare la pipì.
Entrambi avranno in corpo
lo stesso mix ormonale
a base di cortisolo, per esempio,
l'ormone dello stress,
quello che nel mio esordio,
un po' volutamente forte,
vi ha fatto sperimentare
un po' di adrenalina;
un po' di testosterone,
perché il testosterone serve
per affrontare imprese perigliose.
Stessi ormoni,
stessa reazione fisiologica.
Una persona dirà: "Wow! Bellissimo!
Me la sono fatta sotto dalla paura:
straordinario, voglio fare un altro giro".
E l'altra persona dirà:
"No. No. Basta, basta!
Me la sono fatta sotto dalla paura:
mai più nella vita".
Che cosa cambia?
Cambia la storia che queste persone
si raccontano dell'esperienza.
L'adrenalina, il battito -
io, prima di salire su questo palco,
avevo il battito cardiaco a 120.
Il battito cardiaco a 120
è un battito cardiaco.
Il corpo non lo sa,
se è paura o eccitazione:
ho scelto io di chiamarla eccitazione,
perché se la chiamassi paura
tornerei a Brescia all'istante,
e non farei lo speech.
Questo è il concetto.
Noi siamo la storia che ci raccontiamo:
noi siamo storie che camminano.
E se la storia che vivete non vi piace,
ne potete raccontare un'altra.
Questa è la cura delle parole.
Scegliere con cura le parole,
per fare in modo che le parole
si prendano cura di noi,
perché - e questa è la frase
con la quale vi saluto,
"Prendetevi cura delle vostre parole
e le vostre parole
si prenderanno cura di voi".
E grazie per essere stati con me.
(Applausi)
Odore di ascella!
Non male.
(Applausi)
Buona giornata.